las vegas is celebrating the
contributions of the asian and pacific
islander community here in las vegas
tomorrow special events start at
discovery children's museum they run all
month long
hector mejia is there live this morning
downtown with a preview hector good
morning to you
hey there john good morning and they are
celebrating five different
cultures here at the museum and we have
one special performance here
a very special treat for all of us in
the morning
very peaceful let's go ahead and listen
for just a few minutes
[Music]
joining us to talk about the special
performances coming to the discovery
children's museum we have um
sam nelson good morning tell us about
gary so this is gary and his wife
sheldon gary is a member of the
discovery family he's our facilities
director
and he's also a musician and he'll be
performing with us
that's uh really cool and this is just
one example right we have five different
cultures to highlight
for the entire month definitely so we're
gonna do hawaii samoa
japan china and thailand and gary is
hawaiian and he'll be our performer
during the month of may and it's really
like an entire week for each
for each culture one hundred percent
yeah we're going to do a full week for
each of the different cultures
and starting the week off on the
weekends we're going to have performers
or
artists come in to highlight those
cultures all right let's go over to this
table we have markers we have
glue and scissors and a whole bunch of
other items
why we're going to also be doing crafts
throughout all the weeks
that are traditional to the different
cultures we're going to be highlighting
and which place is being highlighted
first it's this weekend right
yes so starting on saturday we're going
to start with samoa and we're going to
do
an art workshop on saturday for samoa
all right
well let's go ahead and listen into uh
our musical performance here from gary
for another few seconds
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you very much and so uh this is
again just one example
it all starts tomorrow this is our sneak
peek again this is all happening here
at discovery children's museum here in
downtown reporting live hector mejia
john
back to you